SPEAKER: We were ordinary women
trying to save women's lives,
but we were criminals.
We were felons.
For most of the nation in '72,
abortion was illegal.
SPEAKER 2:
We had to go underground.
SPEAKER 3:
The woman would be given
the address to the front.
SPEAKER 4: It was probably
obvious to neighbors
what was going on.
SPEAKER 5:
We came to the surface
from other things...
the anti-war movement,
the civil rights movement.
SPEAKER 6:
You couldn't not pay attention
to what was going on.
Fetal death is murder.
SPEAKER 3: You could not work
as a pregnant woman.
SPEAKER 7:
If you weren't married,
you were out of luck.
They were terrible situations.
The septic abortion ward
was full every day.
SPEAKER:
Women did awful things.
They were literally dying
because they were women.
So we thought,
"We can be of use."
I said, "We could use my phone,
but change it
so that they don't ask
for Eleanor.
How about Jane?
Nobody's called Jane anymore."
SPEAKER 8:
We hid the phone numbers
on bulletin boards
around Chicago.
"Pregnant? Call Jane."
The clientele included
daughters, wives, mistresses
of police, states' attorneys,
judges.
SPEAKER 9: It dawned on me
how big an issue this was.
♪ ("FEARLESS"
BY KAT LEON PLAYS) ♪
♪ Go on
Take a stab at my heart ♪
SPEAKER 10: Jane was
an outrageous undertaking
by a lot of smart women.
I was not there
to pass judgment.
SPEAKER 3:
I knew there were women like me.
Under the radar
of the Chicago Mafia
and the police department.
We were all being watched.
The phone rings. A man says,
"We know where you are."
SPEAKER 11: There were
11 counts of conspiracy
to commit abortion,
110 years for each of us.
So that's a long time.
That might have ended Jane
right then and there.
♪ 'Cause I'm fearless
Fearless, fearless ♪
I couldn't see myself
sitting on the sidelines.
SPEAKER:
We were building a new world,
one woman at a time.
♪ Come on, test this, baby
I'm reckless ♪
SPEAKER 13:
Sometimes you have to stand up
to legitimate authority,
and sometimes
there are unjust laws
that need to be challenged.
♪ And you're never gonna
Break me ♪
♪ Never gonna shake me down ♪
♪ Whoa ♪